good evening I want to make a start just
that well welcome tonight's meeting of
the SteriPEN committee my name is Danny
Kendall I'll be chairing tonight's
meeting and according in accordance with
the rules and procedures are set out in
the front page of your agendas before we
start right meeting if I could just give
a brief outline warnings
maybe we could ask Mitch or members of
the public have got their mobile phones
turned to silent please and to also make
you aware of the fact that we could be
filming tonight's meeting as well it
used to be that we were filming it would
go out live at the same time that we're
stopping at the moment it'll be
definitely available on you on the
council's website in the next few days
so if you want to review the meeting you
can do so on the computer on the
council's website should you wish to do
so
right we go to introductions could I ask
people at the top table please just
introduce themselves thank you Thank You
chairman list of also committee services
that illegal services I'm a planning
manager my role is as an impartial
adviser to the committee and to help
answer any questions that arise I'm
bound by the code of Professional
Conduct of the Royal Town Planning
Institute during the meeting I may be
asked to comment on points raised I may
seek clarifications and advise on
planning practice to ensure that
decisions are robust committee members
are not bound by the case officers
recommendation or by oral advice from
officers Thank You Eddie wrench senior
planning officer splendid thank you very
much everybody
okay should we go to our side when she's
apologies for absence perfect and
disclosure of interest exciting - yes
counselor brain agenda item number four
my wife is the applicant I will leave
the room thank you very much any fellow
council Mills thanks mr. chairman on the
third application which I think CF
deferred I'm walk member that for that
particular can I say hello to Brenda
raishin as chief watching thank you
Thank You counselor
okay Thank You councillor Perry German
obviously I do know mrs. brain but I
don't believe it will have any influence
on my decision
except that goes for everyone doesn't it
really counts milk yes most people know
mrs. brain yes thank you
countless of bonds can we just double
check counts the bonds can we just check
this email that you received it was for
item 5 what was the nature of the email
just information about it
yes and the email was just containing
information I didn't touch you no okay
thank you for deferring it that's fine
okay that's sorted then so can I move on
two minutes do you are you happy for me
to sign the minutes of the whole
understand cancer brain because we're
moving the agenda slightly around that's
okay are you happy for me to sign the
minutes 17th of Jan thank you right
before we get started as you all noticed
our final application which item six as
a recommendation to defer my proposal is
that we actually deal with that first so
anybody here for that one
doesn't have to wait around you okay
with that okay so if we go to item six
first thank you this is application
reference 17 / 0 3 2 3 6 / ful and is 14
calm Brook Warnock installation of two
air source heat pumps retrospective
presenting offsets Eddy wrench or Dale
would you like to speak on why it's
being deferred yes thank you a little to
add to the update sheet which sets it
out the noise information needs further
research to ensure that the that it's
robust and that we are making you a
sound recommendation in respect of noise
that's because some further information
has come to our attention so we'd like
to do that work before we bring it back
to you Jeff Thank You Dale now of course
it's in it's up to the committee if
you'd prefer to hear this now you can
but if you'd rather go the defer
option councillor Brent I think we
should go with the officers
recommendation today thank you do I have
a second
councillor Perry all those in favor of
deferring thank you okay so the real
application 17 / 0 3 2 3 6 / ful is
deferred which means we now resume
normal running order and we go to item 4
then this is application reference 17 /
0 3 1 7 6 / very and is from Astin edge
Camden Road Lord Quinton and is for the
variation of condition 2 & 5 and the
removal of condition 6 pursuant to
permission which was of course passed a
while ago 16 / 0 2 4 2 1 / ful
presenting officer Eddie wrench Eddie
Thank You chair the proposed application
is to vary the conditions on the
previous permission in order to
substitute the 12 approved clamping pods
for 12 camping pitches the site is
located and to the west of lower Quinten
on the junction of the B for 6:30 to
Camden Road and Station Road as denoted
here by the black dot in the center of
the screen
the original permission on the site
which was approved by the planning
committee in October 2016 was for a
total of 36 pitches made up of 12
granting pods and 24 camping in caravan
pictures and sighted here is denote a
denoted by the red line this plan shows
the site layout internal road and
landscaping which has already been
agreed through the discharge of
conditions on the original application
the 12 camping pods would have been to
the top left-hand corner of the site and
as shown here they would now be changed
to individual camping pictures finally
this is a photo showing the site and the
current boundary features chairman there
are no updates to report and the
recommendation is to grant permission
subjects the conditions on pages 14 to
16 of the agenda
thank you
thank you and confirm this is only here
because the applicant is a council
employee that is correct
thank you okay we have no reg speakers
and our ward member can't speak does
anyone have an importance of
clarification debate okey-dokey so who
would like to propose something for me
cats the parry very happy to propose
that we go with the officers
recommendation to grant on this
application thank you seconded
council members should we get a vote all
those in favor
thank you therefore the committee
results to grant application reference
17 / 0 3 176 slash Barry move to our
final application of the evening usually
say a lot later than this right this is
a application reference 17 / 0 3 3 3 7 /
ful and it's for one of the LEAs little
Wolford chips moscow and is for the
single and two-story side extension with
single story front extension presenting
officers Harry wrench over to you Thank
You chair the site is located on the
northern end of the village of little
Wolford a short distance from the a3 400
between long Compton and ships turn on
Steaua the site shown here is the black
dots the med center of the screen the
application building is the end of a
terrace of three dwellings and it faces
on two and his access from board more
lane to the south as shown here
this is an aerial view of the site
showing the surrounding residential
development in the vicinity the
application site here shown in red with
the parking to the southeast of the red
line this slide shows the existing
elevations of the property this slide
shows the proposed friends and Easter
elevations which would have which would
have white roof rendering the stone
coins to match the hosting as well as
introduced
some timber where the boarding to the
front this slide is of the other two
elevations to the west and north and
here it is a comparison of the proposed
extension ground floor plan with the
existing ground floor plan on the right
hand side so the extension here is
highlighted in blue this is a photo
taken from the road to the south of the
front elevation of the dwelling with the
front boundary head shown this is
looking east down the lane towards the
application dwelling as picked out here
by the arrow and shown with a white
rendered walls this is looking in the
opposite direction westwards with the
application dwelling on the right the
small gate to the front just but in
front of it is the access to the other
two properties to the north of the
application site this is a photo in the
rough area where the proposed extensions
would be shown so the first floor
extension would come out just on the
side gable there and the front
projection of side projections would
also be in this area this is a view from
the adjoining property to the north and
number two the Lee's this will show the
back of what is the proposed extension
to a number one the Lee's
chairman there is one verbal updates to
the report where the the report should
say that the parish councils support the
application on page 19 and not object
chairman the recommendation is to refuse
for the reasons detailed on page 23 of
the agenda
thank you thank you Eddie so our first
speaker counselor during please from
little north of parish council
welcome so there's a button in the
middle press that you say about six
inches away from me from the mic in the
middle should go red when you oh there
we go
this one thank you very much you have
three minutes if you remain seated for
any questions at the end I'll give you a
warning in the final ten seconds of your
time if that's okay okay hope you very
much the pair of the wolf what counsel
feels strongly to approve this
application we had meeting and we spoke
to the local residents and the neighbors
and had a vote and it was agreed 16200
and even one of the direct neighbors
wrote a letter of support for this and
you need to know that little wolf fort
is a very old community and the
community felt that there is a need for
housing for a young family that just
have adopted two children and they need
to extend the house so this family can
grow up in our little community I would
disagree with the points of the planning
officer that it destroys the character
and the distinctiveness of the area as
this house was built in 1952 and does
not consist of the nice natural
Cotswolds stones rather this application
would improve the look of the house and
tahrir iterate the parish would rather
have this extension and have a young
family there then what is set here to
have the big-deal development that would
be unneighborly it's rather the opposite
it is neighborly and we would feel that
this should be approved thank you very
much Thank You councillor any questions
please parish council Laban's
FR is the neighbor away the neighbours
was there
at the meeting and there are actually
three neighbors one is directly to I
think adjacent to the house one is
behind and oneness on the other side of
the road so I've got one question
presumably my key concern is to do with
the light that will be lost for the
immediately adjacent neighbor number two
the LEAs when you had your meeting did
you speak to the person who lives in
number two and what was their view on
the lighting and the light loss to their
garden well I can't actually let you
speak to anybody else in the room I'm
sorry if you don't have it no I don't I
don't have the answer would have to ask
the applicant forever but okay it was
not raised this issue that's fine don't
worry
any other questions councillor fielding
street parking
perhaps that'd be a question for the
officer okay in that case if there are
no further questions Council thank you
very much thank you okay we have no
board member so should we get councilor
fielding do you want to raise your point
of clarification parking I didn't hear
the comments that were made by the
officer is it going to be talking now
the site currently benefits from to
existing parking spaces which is shown
in this area here so that property
actually has and that's not going to
change with this application so it's all
off road chairman I'm sorry I've just
realized through my work a client of
ours we manage properties that is a is
adjacent its property so I will sit down
Thank You councillor Mills Thank You
Shirley
could you put the the plan of a game
please for me
that's it was one of the reasons refusal
it didn't fit in with the street scene
is it what is concern yeah they're the
scale and dominance I think is not
considered to be subservient to the main
dwelling I just want to confirm that
yeah yeah the exact wording should be on
page 23 just want you to say DK yeah
okay thanks yes counselor bonds
extension from presumably is the one at
the back number two this is the neighbor
and not the neighbor on the other side
there's three neighbors this is number
one the leads number two is obviously
adjoining yeah because it's at a row of
three techno terrors just two short
elevations number two which is the
neighbor we're talking about is this
property here so this is the application
dwelling and then this is the neighbor
and as shown here this is the profile
basically of the neighbor so that's
their existing our house building and
then this is where the proposed two
story element comes in so this is their
two-story ensuite attachment and then
this is the single-story apart
that's right directly to the north I'll
show you our yeah that the pop do is
just showing there is the is this
property here which is number two the
lease which is basically that's the one
that forms refused or reason to the
impact on the extension which would be
around this area so the overbearing
aspect is basically on this rear aspect
of that house
that parking for the neighbor I believe
there's actually that's this bit here
you mean yeah that's all associated with
with this property okay
councillor Donald with the proposed
extension what percentage of the plot
will be taken up by the building
this is going to take a minute to to to
calculate chairman if you're happy with
a rough estimate it's less than 50
percent beyond that it's going to take
several minutes afraid it's not a figure
we prepared I'm sorry
cats oh darling you're content with an
approximation would you like us to count
it
no so we said it's less than 50 percent
thank you any other points for
clarification yes cats the brain who
talks about the wider local area being
within the AI and B it's this property
within
it's in the a and B yes that's correct
caster fielding what about the
conservation areas or a conservation
area in the village if it's not in the
conservation area this is the local area
so yeah there's no conservation area
sure there is a listed building which is
down here but it's quite some distance
from the application site so any other
questions some clarification on have it
has there been a letter of support from
number to the one that's going to be
affected not from that property no not
the adjoining property the there's being
a support letter from this neighbor here
and also the owner of the farm but we
don't know the thoughts of the person
who's directly affected
there's been no comments from them don't
thank you there are no more points of
clarification so we go to the debate
counts the mills thanks for chairman I
gosh this is so for me this is a
difficult one with chairman I can see
why they want to extend it looks at it
to me that plan it doesn't fit in with a
with the existing area at all
with the neighboring properties I'm a
bit torn on this one mr. chairman at the
moment I'm going to go with the officers
decision this I don't like to do it
because you know it's this is to improve
the life of the other people who live
there and their family so um I hated my
best about I'm really sitting on the
fence but
I'll think on this one Thank You
councillor bonds last big I couldn't
understand the pictures and when I went
now to look at the site the situation to
me didn't look to me as though the light
loss was was going to be against the
neighbor that the neighbor that we think
all the people in the village of porous
nobody's against it I appreciate the
planning up a series but then democracy
and the less than fifty percent increase
on the house an old house that could be
used with to what our peoples adopted
children now or whatever I would be
happy to proposal okay
yes I've got council brain next similar
way on this one I mean yes I see the
support the ward members not here to
support it
the neighbors supported the parish
council support it doesn't make it right
okay well it is a large extension quite
a number of policies it's against an air
core strategy it's a difficult to decide
I mean at the moment I would err on the
side of the officers they've got it
right because there's a number of
policies for refusal but council
fielding just a bit of clarification
that grab it going north of the building
there what is that that serve their
neighboring properties so that the
application site is number one the LEAs
the first gray s part is number two
delays and then the other adjoining so
the end row of the three Terrace is the
number three which just goes off page
that's right yeah it's a terrace of
three dwellings okay anyone else in the
debate councillor Crump yeah I'm saying
it's it's good the parish council here a
bit here to support and and obviously
they're reflecting the views
a little while fit and obviously support
from the neighbors but the one thing
that stands out for me is it's in the
Cotswolds area of outstanding natural
beauty so I don't think it's quite right
whether people can come back again and
tinker Willis and improve it I would be
happy then if there were some changes to
potentially support it at the moment I
don't think it's quite right and I would
probably go with officers recommendation
but not saying but saying that doesn't
preclude me in the future if it does
come back in a different format
I wouldn't say support it so that's
where I'm at the moment counts the mills
thanks it almost said what's going to
say is it's just the design of it at the
moment and I was going to say if it
could have been altered that fits in
with the design of the dwellings out
there already it's again future I will
hopefully support it I find this very
very difficult but it's this design of
it mr. Chairman I thank you yes can't so
Donald I think actually I'm on both
sides of this one because the the reason
for extension is obviously an important
one to house a young family with adopted
children as well the continuity of
situation and the tight-knit community
which livable that is representing this
evening and it's so refreshing to have a
posh council come and support an
application and the fact a number of
people have been involved in that
engagement is important I'm little
inside we don't know what their feelings
are I've enabled lead that is most
likely to be affected by the extension
and I'm with cancer Crump that if it was
just perhaps more in keeping with the
street scene and the area of natural
beauty that might be slightly more
fitting for an extension on this but
it's a difficult one because the reason
is so important for the extension
councillor fielding considering that the
neighbor was at the parish council
meeting and from the indications we
he didn't complain about the proposal we
we don't know that doing we number two
we don't know that a number of people
were there but we don't know for sure so
we can't make that assumption counsel I
thought the indication from the parish
council was live anyway I okay what one
one voice okay it's it's not in the
conservation here it may be in the Aon B
it enhances the property I'm airing us
with councillor Barnes on this and I
think that if they come back with
another design it's going to go through
why can't we let one go through at the
present moment so I mean okay it is in
the a OMB yes yeah it's it's in
speculate right capsular blame that I
want to move this longer counseling but
we can't assume that if it comes back in
a different form that it would be
acceptable right add my thoughts I think
I'm exactly with you counter O'Donnell
that I really really want to say yes to
this but I'm afraid it is going against
a policy it's quite clearly and again I
my view would have been changed had we
had a really clear letter of support
from number two we don't know what
number to think and I think that would
be that would change my view a lot but
we don't know and I think we we need to
arrow side of caution of this it's not
quite right it's not quite right then it
must be wrong so I'm gonna move the
other way on this one so we do however
have a proposition I think from
councillor Barnes Council bounds you you
propose that we grant this you did say
that so we have to take that further do
we have a seconder for that
and that would be seconded by Councillor
fielding we should if everyone's content
to go through the vote on that proper is
proposed to ground it's been seconded
those in favor of granting yes
we okay we would need to have the
reasons counselor bounce you propose
grant what would your reasons be for
granting looking at when I went to the
Stars I didn't think it was going to be
a large inclusion there was a lead for
it in a village which is in the village
that doesn't have development and as far
as I was concerned there it was
acceptable in that position okay things
not fair for purposes and I think we
would want if it wills to be passed and
it would be the condition yes no only
when it's against the officers
recommendation and we and the
recommendation will be the proposition
will be to grant so if it is granted we
would need to know the conditions before
we grant it otherwise you might want to
change the conditions okay so yes and
remove the PD but no yeah so those would
be the usual grant air conditions I
presume you be happy with that so those
in favor of granting based on what's
just been said please show CJ there's
against granting five change so the
proposition fails in on this one I would
propose then that we go with the
officers recommendation and refuse with
what's been said you know so far in
terms of I don't think it's the
principle of the house extension there's
a problem I think it's definitely this
particular plan which is important so I
would propose that we refuse do I have a
seconder for that
councillor grandpa thank you all those
in favor of refuse are based on those
reasons
4:5 chairman thank you those against one
way chairman thank you therefore the
committee resolves to refuse application
reference 17 / 0 3 3 3 7 / ful that is
our last application for evening there's
no urgent business unusually quite short
tonight thank you very much the meeting
is closed